MELANIE PARKER: Hi, everyone.
My name is Melanie Parker.
I'm Chief Diversity
Officer for Google.
I'm joined by James Heighington,
our Global Head of Diversity
Strategy for this session.
All of you in this
session today know
the demand for cloud
technology solutions
has ramped up dramatically
these few months.
The need for reliable tools that
help teams collaborate remotely
has never been greater.
As your companies make
decisions about whether you're
working from home
or the office, you
might be starting to wonder how
that will impact your workplace
culture.
You're probably
asking questions like,
how's the real value of my
businesses workplace culture?
How might we continue
to foster community
and belonging with a more
distributed workforce?
How are my company's decisions
influencing its commitments
related to diversity,
equity, and inclusion?
I'll be upfront.
I don't have all the answers.
I'm wrestling with the
same questions, too.
In fact, our CEO, Sundar Pichai,
was recently asked about this.
He mentioned how
our campuses have
been designed to foster
collaboration and community, as
well as chance encounters
that lead to innovation.
But he also said
that we're looking
at the data and the feedback
from employees with an eye
toward offering more
flexibility to work
from home in the future.
These conversations are ongoing.
And there are still many
unknowns about the future.
But today, what is
clear is we need
to have a deep understanding
of our workforce
before we begin to insert
DEI into the dialogue
in a meaningful way.
And one of the key ways we
reveal our understanding
of our workforce
and the progress
we're making through DEI is
through our Diversity Annual
Report.
We've published it
the past six years.
And we just recently
released the 2020 report.
So today, I want
to share with you
how we're building a workforce
that reflects all communities,
as well as some of
the DEI strategies
we're using to cultivate a
sense of belonging at this time.
Every year since 2014, we've
published our Diversity Annual
Report.
We were one of the first
to do so in our industry.
The report is
anchored on the fact
that there's some
underrepresented groups who
have historically
been discriminated
against and excluded
from opportunities
and who today remain affected
by systemic racism, xenophobia,
and the like.
We continually try
to look at our data
and capture more nuances
about all of the people who
work at Google.
We always want to see more
humanity in the report.
Everyone wants to see themselves
reflected and validated.
I should also note that we
have supplements to this data,
including a survey called
Self-ID, which is global.
Through it, we're
starting to expand
how we look at our workforce.
So with that backdrop, I
want to share with you what
we're learning along the way.
This report provides one of the
largest publicly available DEI
data sets in our industry.
This data represents real people
who make real contributions
to our mission and our culture.
And we must keep in
mind that human element.
Data drives everything
Google does, from the way
we develop products
to the way we
design our diversity, equity,
and inclusion efforts.
Before we dive in, a couple
quick notes on our data--
first, we include gender data
globally and race in the US.
Around the world, there are
various government protections
on what data we must collect,
as well as what data we cannot
collect.
This report is aligned with
standard business practices
for multinational
corporations, even
as we find new ways to collect
more globally inclusive
data through Self-ID.
Second, we use a plus sign
in all our racial categories
to indicate multiracial
people are plussed
in to each racial category.
Previously,
multiracial people were
counted in a single
category, which doesn't fully
represent their identity.
We made this change
to be more inclusive.
With DEI, most people think
of the data surrounding
how our workforce is
growing to better reflect
the communities we serve.
These changes in our
workforce representation
are largely driven by two
inputs, hiring and attrition.
Let's start with hiring.
Google did well in
several key ways in 2019
when it comes to hiring.
We have both tech and
nontech jobs at Google.
Last year, we saw the largest
increase for Black tech
hiring we've ever measured.
We also look at new hires, our
"newglers," as we call them.
We're pleased that
Black newglers now
make up the largest
underrepresented racial group
in nontech hiring.
We measure success
in other ways, too.
For example, a
Googler-built tool
helped us identify
and remove gender bias
from job postings, which
helped us to increase
women applicants for many jobs.
And our internship program,
which is remote this summer,
continued to build
broader pathways to tech.
We still want to see
stronger hiring growth
in some underrepresented
groups, such as
Native American Googlers.
And we'll try to focus
on that this year.
In addition to hiring,
it's equally important
to focus on retaining Googlers
from all underrepresented
groups.
With that in mind,
our Latinx community
is the first
underrepresented group
to see attrition
rates for both women
and men below the average,
a positive development,
even though there was a slight
increase for Latinx women.
Women on average at Google
still had lower attrition rates
than men.
At the same time, attrition
rates for Black women
are now higher than
average attrition rates.
How do we do better with
regards to retention?
One strategy is we
build on what works.
For example, we have what we
call "retention equity teams."
84% of Googlers who went
through that program
have decided to stay at Google.
We're already building
on that number this year,
which is critically
important because retention
is going to play a
key role in helping us
achieve our aspirational goals.
We've covered hiring
and attrition.
Let's see where Google landed
with representation overall.
We saw continued growth in
representation for women
globally, as well as for Black
and Latinx Googlers in the US.
We also had the largest increase
in Black+ representation
overall and in technical roles
since we began publishing.
For the second year in a row,
we maintained our growth rate
of representation of women
in leadership roles globally.
We also see further proof that
our internal mobility programs
are paying off.
Last year, the increase
in women leadership
was attributable mostly
to promotions, not hiring.
And this year, we see a similar
trend for our Latinx leaders.
Tracking the annual data
is very useful in working
towards goals in
hiring, retention,
and overall representation.
Let's zoom out of it and look
at trends over multiple years.
The fact is, in recent
years, we have scaled up
our diversity, equity,
and inclusion initiatives
to match the pace
of Google's growth.
Since 2014, Google's
global headcount
has increased by 170% and
our US headcount by 180%.
As you can see, the growth rate
of underrepresented Googlers
has generally grown even faster.
This demonstrates an
ongoing commitment
to what we call "responsible
growth," with these percentage
points representing thousands
of new underrepresented Googlers
joining.
This data is
critically important.
And I hope all of you
have taken that first step
to start gathering data to
help guide your DEI strategies
and goals.
But obviously, the work
doesn't stop there.
In Google's case,
we're actually working
in a larger context of our
societal responsibility
to build a robust, diverse
talent pool for our industry.
We must not only focus on
Google's immediate hiring
needs, but also on long-term,
systemic solutions.
Consider this.
Someone born in 1998, the
year Google was founded,
is only now
completing university.
Preparing the
next-generation workforce
for the increasingly
technical nature of work
requires long-term
partnerships with government,
educational initiatives,
policymakers,
and community organizations.
And on that note, I want to turn
it over to James Heighington.
JAMES HEIGHINGTON: Thank you.
As Melanie stated,
we view our work
within the larger context of
our societal responsibility
that we have at Google to
build a robust, diverse talent
pool for our industry.
And that's why, in 2019, we
strengthened our partnerships
with both local organizations
and local communities.
And we started to expand
the vision of our work
to include not only education,
but entire ecosystems
in the communities
that we call home.
We're addressing these
systemic challenges head-on.
And we're doing so in order
to responsibly grow our talent
and meet industry demand.
This past year, we
implemented versions
of this holistic strategy in
places like Atlanta, London,
and cities around
India by engaging
with not just the
educational sector,
but with local businesses,
community organizations,
elected officials, even urban
planning and real estate
developers.
This reflects how Google
and these communities
can come together to
invest in shared success
and realize mutual benefits.
The issues that we're
facing are systemic.
And it's our responsibility to
help address them and invest
back into the communities
and infrastructure that
support our growth.
As Google continues to grow,
we have a responsibility
to scale our diversity, equity,
and inclusion initiatives
and increase pathways to
tech in the communities
that Google calls home.
It's important to think
about the end state here
of what we're actually working
towards when we think about
diversity, equity,
and inclusion.
This is not about diversity
just for the sake of diversity.
This is not just about the heads
that we have sitting at desks.
But this is about creating
a real sense of value
for the experiences
and expertise
that everybody brings
to their work every day.
And those experiences
and expertise
can help improve our company,
our products, and the services
that we provide.
But in order to truly
unlock that value
from every one of
our employees, we
need to ensure that
everyone feels included.
We need to ensure
that everyone feels
like they belong at Google.
Inclusion means everyone.
And that also means
the job of creating
an inclusive environment
is a job for everyone.
At Google, we believe
this is not just
the role of the diversity team.
This is a shared responsibility
among every employee
that works at our company.
And what we need
to do is make sure
that we are not just
accelerating this work,
but that we are
expanding this work
and doing so so
that every Googler--
in particular, those from
underrepresented groups--
experiences an
inclusive workplace.
On this journey, we can
measure how we are doing.
And we do measure
how we're doing
through a series
of internal indexes
that we have created here
at Google and also by using
external indexes that we have.
For example, in 2019, we were
proud to file the Disability
Equality Index.
And we use these indexes
to benchmark our efforts
and make improvements
as we go along.
These indexes
aren't an end state.
They are guideposts that
we use on our journey.
When we started reporting
this data in 2014,
we used the data that we had
available on hand at that time.
And as Melanie mentioned,
that's the data
that we had collected through
mandatory government reporting
obligations.
But as our understanding
of diversity, equity,
and inclusion has
grown, so, too,
has the need for a more
robust and inclusive data set.
And we've responded by
introducing a new data set.
And that is Self-ID.
The goal of this is to have
a more global and more fully
inclusive data set that we
can use to expand our DEI
work in a data-driven way.
Google is one of the only
companies in our industry
to collect this amount of
information on a global scale.
And here's how we've been able
to put some of this data to you
so far.
We've hosted five
Women of Color Summits
around the globe
over the past year
to ensure that we are
focusing on the intersectional
experiences of women of
color at all the Google
offices that we have.
We've also used this
data to continue
to expand the
company-wide goals that we
have around accessibility.
In addition, we use this data
to analyze the company pulse
survey that we do every year
and ensure that we are looking
at results by race and gender,
in addition to things like
disability status,
nonbinary genders,
veterans and military service,
for the LGBTQ+ communities,
and age as well.
When we also think
of inclusive, it's
important that we
are being inclusive
of more demographic identities.
But we also want
to ensure that we
are being inclusive
in more regions
and taking a global
approach of our DEI work.
At Google, we have more
than 100,000 employees
spanning nearly 60 countries.
Operating at this level brings
an extra layer of complexity
to everything that we do.
At the same time, we
need to balance that
by recognizing diversity,
equity, and inclusion
is unique to every region.
We need to ensure that
we are understanding
each local context
and developing
local strategies in response.
And this year's diversity
report reflects that work,
with nearly half of the
content coming from outside
of the United States.
What you see on the screen
is just part of the work
that we've done
over this past year.
We are continuing to
invest in this work.
And we are committed to
telling more global DEI
stories about our
work as we go forward.
All of the work that
we've been talking about
highlights how we are building
a culture of belonging.
And for more on that, I'll
turn it over to Melanie
to wrap us up.
MELANIE PARKER: Thank you, Jim.
As we move further
into 2020, Google
is anchoring on the
common thread that
binds all of our DEI efforts.
Belonging describes a
vision that we continually
aim to achieve.
We can't see our colleagues
in person due to COVID-19.
But it's inspiring
to me to see how
our Googlers are finding
creative ways to cultivate
a sense of belonging.
For example, our
employee resource groups
are hosting music,
trivia, and dance parties
on Google Meet, our
video conferencing tool.
Groups of Googlers are
also pulling together
to volunteer their time and
expertise to important causes
that help communities
affected by COVID-19.
And on a larger scale,
Google and google.org
are supporting many
organizations and communities
within Google and
across the globe,
leveraging our
tech and our funds.
I'm sure that many of your
companies and your employees
have been engaged in
similar activities
to the ones I just described.
The COVID-19 situation
will continue
to shape all of our DEI work.
For Google, that means
we must continually
renew our commitment
to serving communities
with the greatest needs and
ensuring equity for all.
We have to take steps to help
Googlers feel like they belong,
even if they aren't physically
back in a Google office
just yet.
We want to understand
what belonging truly means
and what needs to be done so
that all Googlers can continue
to help us cocreate our culture
and that we leave no one out.
I hope that some of the
information that we've
shared in our session today
has spurred some ideas for you
to consider in
your own DEI work,
from how you track
workforce representation
to your global DEI strategies.
Have a great day.